let's jump into this uh the first story
and this was the big news that's
trending on Twitter right now Tucker
goes full conspiracy theorist on Twitter
I love this today the mail they are not
too happy with Tucker's position on the
war in Ukraine because Daily Mail of
course is super pro Ukraine but they say
x Fox host debuts his new show and rants
about the West's unwavering support for
Ukraine questions why UFO whistleblower
is not dominating the news and says
Americans live in ignorance
um okay so what was he wrong about yes
the West is just insanely obsessed with
Ukraine and there's tons of Lies I like
how uh there's a meme going on right now
because of this uh this Dam that got
blown up they were like in three months
they're gonna come back and be like oh
yeah we knew it the whole time right The
Washington Post reported that apparently
we knew about the the attempts to
sabotage the Nordstrom pipeline well in
advance and so now when it comes to
blowing up this Dam in in uh in Ukraine
they're claiming Russia did it surprise
prize surprise it'll probably be in
three months they'll say actually it was
Ukraine who did it but anyway look I'm
not I'm not trying to ignite that whole
conversation deep foreign policy stuff
we can get into in a second the big
story is just that Tucker Carlson has
returned he cannot be stopped episode
one he just posts it's got 148 000 likes
and the big picture here is the media is
officially dead the corporate media it's
over man I longed for this day so I
remember this at 6 PM I just want to
talk her if you can move I'm streaming
at 6 PM so I'd appreciate it if you like
slid over Tucker Carlson because we did
okay today but I think if he keeps this
up he might steal our audience and
Tucker Carlson posted his first episode
the first episode of his show on June
6th at 6 pm
ooh I mean I would love to conspiracy
theorize with you all but I did do an
episode today on June 6th at 6 P at 6
p.m I can't I didn't mean to really it
wasn't on purpose well it never is but
it happened yeah maybe you're right the
road it wasn't my first episode it
wasn't my first episode though I think
people are gonna need to evolve to start
being able to listen to two
conversations at once because there's
too many shows at six o'clock you just
gotta put two on it maybe two and then
three and then four just pick the show
that you like and you watch the show
that you like and if you guys all make
videos here you should put on videos of
yourself to listen to yourself and then
put on multiple videos of yourself at
the same time it's like heightened
evolution
how many views does that have oh let's
find out I am looking right now
so it's been up for two hours and it has
nine million wow my gosh that has more
views I just want you to know this is so
popular he is popular and he should be
my dad loves him I don't actually know
much about Tucker Carlson he used to be
like deep State chill without realizing
like he was in The Matrix he wore a bow
tie and just did talking points for the
military industrial complex and then he
had this interview with Jon Stewart
where he was humiliated Jon Stewart
humiliated him and he like went into
some deep mental place like and then he
came out like is this new creature of
Truth and and now he's like why was he I
disagree yeah like what he I don't think
he was I I disagree with you on that
does he has he said that's why he
transformed I don't think Stewart uh
humiliated him I thought Stewart's uh
performance was even a little
embarrassing because Jon Stewart like he
was calling Tucker Carlson out for
things that he claimed were uh
mistruthed and Tucker responded by
saying well actually you said this on
your show and that isn't true and Jon
Stewart goes it's a comedy show as if
Jon Stewart isn't trying to convince
people of things because he's just a
comedian it was really really slimy
duplicitous it was very duplicitous
because you can't have it both ways you
can't say like I do an educational
comedy show that teaches people things
and then when someone calls you out for
misinformation say let's it's a comedy
show who cares but that's exactly what
Jon Stewart it's just a joke when I say
a thing that happened is true followed
by a joke exactly exactly what Jon
Stewart and the rest of his ilk do is
they'll say here's a true thing that
happened and now joke and it's like then
they claim the lie was the joke the
whole time exactly so they'll say like
Sheamus was seen kicking dogs was the
dog which did happen but there's a
justification for it I don't put that
into right right so the point is they'll
say Sheamus kicked a dog and then that's
the fact and then they go and was the
dog Snoopy like some ridiculous nonsense
yeah and then everyone laughs and then
later though like the whole thing was a
joke you know like Sheamus never kicked
a dog and be like no we were joking yeah
exactly so they'll talk about about it
like it's news plus jokes and then when
they get called out for saying something
that wasn't true they go oh no but it's
just a joke what's the big deal so I
seem to remember Tucker there's like
2003 four or five while ago yeah he was
like just basically like the Warner rack
is good uh Barack Obama's bad and all
the Republicans are good and the
Democrats are bad and that was like not
I was in the zone of like Obama's good
you know war is bad but he was like but
we and something happened right around
that Jon Stewart interview with them
where he changed like he he disappeared
for a year came out and he lost the bow
tie and he got way more serious I missed
the bow tie I do miss the bow tie but uh
I know I remember that interview
you're right that Tucker Carlson was
very much like a typical like kind of
neocon broadcast well that's what the
bow tie was for so that when you were
looking at him and he was saying that we
need to go blow up foreigners you were
like put that bow tie there is like it's
just so funny it is a nice bow tie he's
like I tied it myself the other thing uh
ideas maybe he did a bunch of mushrooms
one day I don't think why is that always
it why can't someone just come to
realize something true without doing a
bunch of mushrooms wouldn't it be great
so that that interview made him like
change his opinions on the Iraq War I
don't think it does no Ian's just crazy
I'm just kind of throwing one out there
I don't know if it was that interview
but around that time of his life he kind
of had this he changed momentum he
switched all his opinions at some point
not all of them but like he he began to
oppose the um the kind of
neo-conservative foreign policy
perspective because he used to be very
much in lockstep but the rest of the
right wing at that time which was saying
yes our freedom is over in the Middle
East let's go get Osama Bin Laden bad we
were attacked 911 terrorists two
airplanes I'm being snide I'm being
snied right but neoconservatism is
intellectually bankrupt it's just a form
of Marxism oh I I feel like they just
co-opted the conservative movement this
neo-war now they're victims Trump kicked
him out though I was so young when all
that stuff was going on like I don't
even how old were you in 06
uh I was 10. oh yeah we're like the same
age yeah yeah about the same age I
remember those did you watch that stuff
when you were back then I so I watched a
little bit yeah my my I used to you know
when we would drive anywhere we didn't
listen to music in the car it was always
talk radio always talk radio and so I
heard a lot of it my you know my dad is
one of those guys who he listens to both
sides uh at that time he definitely did
and so I heard uh unfortunately I I
heard my fair share of NPR as well but
yeah you know a lot of like Rush
Limbaugh Michael Savage uh the the OG's
yeah my dad used to listen to them too
but I didn't know what they were talking
about I was so confused I was like fire
like little 10 year old chambers of
Spider-Man
I was like Dad turn the radio off
scary man is yelling yeah really bad
Phenom country I think part of Tucker
Tucker's like what I love about him is
that he used to be a neocon used to be
like in The Matrix and now he's out of
it like yeah I love the the retribution
story that come come from behind Victory
what do you what do you mean in The
Matrix because when we say that like we
talk about like dating and relationships
I'm curious what you guys it's in like
the political world well you explained
it first like what is what is the dating
Matrix
um it's just kind of like men grow up
thinking that like women want the guy
that gives them flowers treats them well
and they grow up and find out that's not
true right right and there's the red
pill there's they actually they get kind
of mad at me because there's so many
like people have so many different
definitions of it so they kind of argue
over it but that's like in layman's term
about the Matrix Yeah well yeah like the
red pill because a lot of people use
that word for so many different things
but but so I'm curious in the political
world what you guys mean like the
literal Matrix yeah I thought like
there's a there's so the political red
pill is there is a corporate there is a
corporate narrative that the average
person believes is reality and if you
are to quote unquote take the red pill
you wake up to the untruths that is the
corporate press the media politics for
the establishment narrative 911. like I
was fed I thought okay a couple of
planes hit the buildings they knocked
them down and Osama Bin Laden's the one
that's responsible for all of this okay
and then I found out later like oh
there's a lot of evidence that there's
more to it than in just a couple of
planes and this dude in the Middle East
I think Saudi Arabia got sued over their
involvement or something what was that I
don't know I don't know I don't want to
get into it because I don't know if
about it but there was like there's
there's a lot more that is a rabbit are
you guys like bushed at 9 11. no we
don't we don't all share the same
opinion we're actually pretty diverse
panel to be honest yeah yeah I don't
have any evidence of who did it but
there's a lot more going on than what I
thought like the way the buildings fell
down in near free Falls like dirt so
instead of just getting into a whole 911
debate yeah
what the red pill is yeah I would say
for me like the political Matrix there's
a couple different things and I usually
don't use terms like the red pill or the
Matrix for the reason that you described
which is that they're thrown around by
so many people to represent so many
different things but I would say that in
one sense The Matrix is sort of like all
the the social political ideas that are
forced onto people that they're
convinced of that are untrue and I would
say one of those at least in the dating
Marketplace is just you know the sexual
Revolution more generally speaking this
idea that people are happy when they
have sex outside of marriage that this
is something people should aspire to do
and that it's a healthy way for man to
live and that we're just a product of
our own self-invention and as long as a
person is getting their sexual
gratification what they're doing is
beyond reproach basically thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time